now listen you are gonna accept the
crater you can't run away from it look
we Mindy yes you you right now right now
on camera what's this why is this here
looks like a book to me yeah we know
that but what's what what do we have it
at work some words learning some words
what do we call was information yes this
information if it just says that's it we
are never told how so Miss Bishop came
to realize that Aniyah is that
information for a stop sometime yeah
okay if there's information it requires
somebody wrote why maybe I'll read it no
maybe keep myself because in my charge
no visitors but I my experience of the
world I have never seen a book that
wrote that thing about myself
good so I've only ever seen books that
people wrote for the purpose of good
okay now you said look a check this out
yeah I'll go maybe came by truck it goes
no I don't think it came by okay ah
look look why because this is called the
fitnah innate disposition is live in an
office that boom BAM it's not happening
you know this cannot come by chance
information requires it starts with an
eye intelligence know the camera is
quite clever I like that yeah because he
doesn't want anybody coming to see that
camera came here by yourself he wants
some credit he's like Thomas recording
you must even times it is already good
if information requires intelligence
I'll go a bit complex and sophistication
the DNA a single strand of DNA has more
information than every single
now what did we see this is one book how
the hope of some Hispanic intelligence
information requires intelligence DNA
more information than this book hundred
million times if there's information in
the DNA what does it require if there's
information in the DNA coding yeah
programming by mama is working going on
what does it require so for your know
trick tips for your no trick to work
yeah it is gonna work or so right at the
moment call the chicky as well boy is no
trick to work here what you have to do
is equate things in nature which are a
product of the physical forth is with
things that human beings do with their
minds and hands when they write books
what's a way again okay you looked at
this and said that information if
there's information acquired
intelligence yes okay now I went to the
DNA a single strand of the DNA a single
strand of the DNA has more information
in it than a missing the book on this
planet that means if there's information
there it requires what yeah I don't
think that's the to sandwich I don't
think you see I don't think for you to
the whole that I know I'm start be real
row for you to call that information I
need to take something out of nature and
because we as human beings I've broken
it down to into a code that is yeah
outside I'm you know that information as
well and then you say that that also
must have had it is that no bra
nature does those things and sad be real
is the structure inside information look
into my eyes the structure behind
information I'm sorry are you speaking
for the sake of it now why are you
rejecting this obvious point doesn't
make sense okay it makes perfect sense
you know is double standards to come to
this book and mere book and look
information requires intelligence and go
to a DNA which why don't you just why
don't you just say because this has
information in it therefore God must
have done this no no no one being
something but reaching the one you make
this so what could a God have created
nature to make the DNA information
equals intelligence and that just as
well say that the DNA code in nature and
also the intelligence behind it was good
and son if a person I'm not gonna I've
taught you before a person who's genuine
sincerity you know Ali that makes sense
it doesn't make sense and if you say it
doesn't make sense you are lying to your
show I want to make something really
clear this is why I said when I use this
argument and by the way I'm gonna use
this argument to prove the point that I
leave our one no I just want the truth
fear be spoken
my intentions no no listen listen listen
anyone that's watching this at home that
has an utter way of sincerity will say
you know what found that clicked just
looking ahead with an argument or to say
it like yeah no no I'm not here for that
it's not about ego thing so this is
about truth yeah but I show them a
simple example and this is why I
couldn't double standards and hypocrisy
and I don't like it be honest you're not
rejecting a book that has an alpha and I
said can I can this come by chance you
said of course not of course not
somebody look at human like a DNA look a
DNA that's not written in the human
language here and the feelings once
they've looked at nature and translated
in silence and for our own convenience
me just say to me Ali I'm gonna look
into don't even don't make excuses for
it the DNA has more complication is more
complicated more sophisticated then this
book it has the information which is
intelligence
I don't get food with this atheist
vibing look into it I don't know what
happened with you what you went through
bro I'm look I'm told you has a brother
cuz I love you I'm talking hard
arguments inside bro inside
listen to me bro I don't know what I
feel look I of course we things in my
life yeah but just because I go through
them and go through hard times bro it
doesn't mean I reject my faith basis can
jump into something that's crazy
atheism yeah I still see you as a
problem
I still believe what I'm seeing his
family don't just go in this wave of a
teeth and because you know brother look
I give me a simple example your and a
half and I told you tonight I told you
that you equated the fact that
information in a book that we can
logically infer must have had an
intelligent human being right
it's a bloody book in a human language
that side who wouldn't infer that now
then you to turn around and say this is
exactly the same thing when you look at
nature and the DNA code
that some in some agency must have
designed the DNA code now bro that's
nature that's the product of the
physical laws okay wait wait okay I'm
gonna make it simple yes
where did it work where did this complex
DNA came from it was it came over
evolution
nuta where's your evidence because even
even though it's even Darwin he stops at
evolution mostly if they stopped it I
mean they stop at the the first they
stop there how are you making claims
that big changes haven't done well
actually your honor
any development after the first cell is
classified as evolution when different
when you've got different scene for the
first day before the birth after just
terrifying before the first cell was
formed you have a process called
abiogenesis which is the theory of how
we got from chemicals to biology yeah
which is the first living cell now the
theory of that is that there's about six
stages that non-living the material no
materials happen to get together and
form amino acids get together and form
chains I got together and form RNA RNA
was the precursor to DNA three out of
these six processes have been replicated
in scientific laboratories already know
yeah now it's not a conclusive theory
but it is a very good understanding of
how we got DNA which is through RNA no
so to form a protein 150 amino acids
long you've got a one in two chance at
each site of getting the correct type of
linkage so you got one and 2 x 1 + 2 x 1
+ 2 x 1 + 2 to the what power that
linkages we have a hundred 49 but call
150 it turns out that one in two to the
150 is equal is the same number as 10 to
the 45th one in ten to the forty five so
now we got to eat incredibly improbable
things that we've got to overcome to
build a functional protein by chance
alone and more problem when you're
building proteins amino acids come in
two flavors there's a left-handed flavor
and a right-handed flavor
they're called optical isomers not
flavors okay and the left-handed version
is the only kind that can be used in
building proteins to get even one
right-handed amino acid in there and
your protein won't fold properly so you
got another probabilistic hurdle to
overcome so you've got a one in two
chance and each side again out to the
hundred fiftieth power to two 150th
power again is ten to the 45
oh my goodness so the odds of building
even a short functional protein by
chance alone is 74 plus warning huh
thank you very much okay
Wow now can anyone get their mind around
a number that big there's only 10 to the
80th elementary particles in the entire
universe there's only 10 to the 16th
seconds since the the Big Bang there's
only 10 to the 139th total events since
the beginning of the universe now you're
starting to get the understanding of why
people are very skeptical but the chance
hypothesis is gonna do the job does
anyone ever gotten in a discussion with
you about the origin of life and said
hey it happened by chance do you hear
that I mean this happens to me I'm out
and I'll be lecturing in Hospital
University environments and I'll get
done and somebody say well but but they
want to argue with me about the
probabilities and I just shut the
discussion down because I say no serious
scientist thinks this is the way it
happened it's it's always gonna be more
probable that it didn't happen by chance
than it did it's not my fault that he
doesn't know no serious scientist thinks
this is the way it happened
braava you said to me why I should do is
now going research now probably you are
honest what you would do is go and
research a biogenesis and RNA scientists
got so stuck with this you know what
they said aliens bro it's still a
possibility bro it's still a possibility
[Music]
someone else and a be spread from planet
to planet by asteroids I said how can we
exist the reason I tell you the reason
for that because they have found in in
space for chains of molecules which were
the same chains of molecules here in
this bro alien just means yeah
extraterrestrial extraterrestrial I call
si bar with the argument I don't want to
see
boy ds-82 sorry I don't know outside of
this planet yeah Terra Astro is out
Jeannot Jeannot
do you know what that means when
scientists come to say family first
first Hill aliens you know what that
means no hello darling
darkness is coming the scene Aviance
right wrong that's a joke why is a joke
can I explain what scene it is why I
don't believe them I believe in the
unseen from my I wouldn't you say that
okay fine but connecting was going on
yet now because it hasn't been
conclusively demonstrated how we got
from just chemistry and chemicals to a
biological system of life is not 100%
but a lot of the stages have been done
because there is some gaps there okay
there are theories which say where did
that person and those those chains come
from yeah so there's a possibility that
there was meteorites where we have found
some of these chains already there that
could have landed on earth and bought
the first cell with it or bought the
first combination of things to lead to
the glass yeah you know this is a theory
because it's not conclusive and they're
open to have a possibility okay we don't
know if it is true monkey which is why
hisses one possess it for me it's a
theory we don't know we don't know in
theory you know why because you couldn't
you couldn't you couldn't deny yet guys
I don't need to knew proved up into him
and you can obviously see why you don't
need yeah but I just want to explain you
can have your own ideas you got your own
options
you saying I've got not a leg to stand
on to criticize question what are you
talking about
I'm a human being I refer to scientific
explanations for things when I find them
convincing I still admire them up I
still admit that I still admit that
those scientific models that we use to
explain and control future behavior fine
Roger shut up a second yet those models
that we use yeah ah reasonable because
they're reliable
they give us predictive of which winner
is planetary power so I am happy to
refer to them now when it comes to
things that we don't know about the
origin of the universe whether infinity
can exist I just say I don't know and
the world's greatest experts say they
don't know now this is a prime excuse
for theists to come and say because some
people don't know something and they're
honest enough to admit that we can say
we are sure we've got magical
explanations no no no what we see is we
admire your honesty but stick to your
name that's what we say no no no no my
leg we well it is why should I believe
that there's any dimension outside of
the physical reality he does can
something come from nothing
[Music]
one of the samurai t1 love the line
people Manta nahin or pika and woman
looks like